okay I'm Michael gamma from University
of cooperative education rules Academy
like mine I'm talking here about usage
of Mathematica to detect whether text or
possibly a preggy risen or not this is
me this is Michael gamma or as you like
to pronounce it gamer it's okay for me
because of the results viewer will see
here are the results of playing around
formally with Mathematica us a new data
set feature and I would like to explain
you some things which you can use
Mathematica 10 in detecting plagiarism
so I go over the abstract and just say
two words if you download this
presentation you have an abstract er you
know what it's going on detecting
plagorism is not only not every so easy
like it was in my last holiday last week
in Portugal where I'll solve this famous
pandora on you jewelry originator price
with 18 euros you can every by 40 or 50
it is simple to detect this is a pregger
ism it's not easy to detect this in the
work of the students I'm responsible for
the business information science for the
german see this virtual informatik on a
university of cooperative education
nearby here in radio mark it's about 30
kilometers it's a private university and
the students we have a few students it's
301 hundred of them are studying
Business Information science and so I
have all the work of the students to in
the direct access and the idea was to
fill this in in the new inverse new
version 9 you form gotta set and are
filled in the work of the students in
this data set and then see what we can
do so I took all the works of the
students they have to write down six
reports on their terms in the practical
face as we call it the on a normal
company working there and write down the
report of about 2,500 where
and then finally they have to write a
bachelor thesis which is fifteen
fourteen thousand words and they all
have these texts and the idea is to fill
this first in in a data set the
structure of the data set is seen here
we have a year name the group and so on
and lastly the text we calculate a few
in details here on this store data rate
the rate of different words the word
length and the sentence length of the
words in the text and the means and the
sentence length of every sentence we
have here which gives an idea what we
can do with this text first observation
is I have given on another truck in the
IMS conference in Prague earlier this
year in January that we observe a
decrease in the richness of the texts
written by the students what you see
here is one slide it's the only slide
you see twice if you have been in prac
to recognize this slide it is a
development of the rich richness of the
text the whole last five years we have
on the bachelor thesis about two years
three years ago the students used about
5600 different words to write down their
bachelor thesis which is fourteen
thousand words you see a decline here in
the last year's in the last two years
the average count of different words
students use to write on The Bachelor
sees three thousand six hundred so we
have a dramatically decline here and you
this is what we hear from the company's
our our students are that they are not
able to express precisely in written
form and this is a usage of the words
and when I discovered this in in the
last year and presented in January the
idea was born to do something like
classified we have no the text in the
data set a half the text written from
the students and so we can try to
identify the author of a bachelor thesis
this is the main idea and there are a
few obstacles in Germany something is
very good as I heard in the last days
and something is very
complicated complicated is dealing with
data so we have very their politics to
restrict the use of data I am NOT able
to use every data I have I'm not allowed
to use every data air from the students
so one has to think about how we can
classify this the first one can do a one
word to the code the code is written not
to be optimized for mathematical to use
very few types rogues to get the result
it's optimized for readability so it is
not optimized for Mathematica one can
read it quite simple and the first what
is done here that we I have a look on
the sentence length of the bachelor
thesis and the written reports we have
what you see here is then this for one
group the groups are anonymized I cannot
give you hear the real group names nor
you will see the real names of persons
we have something like present one
persons who peasantry in real this is
gets blurry called Maya or so on and the
groups are with whether you see here in
the first large difference between the
paper it's a bit too large i think i
make a bit smaller you have few other
papers and the bachelor thesis and you
see a real difference the first person
on the left side uses an average
sentence length of 14 15 word percent
written in the records and the bachelor
thesis it has about 23 this is a part
where we may have to do a closer look
you can do a nice bar chart with this so
see it is here identified as what is it
person aight who has forty seven percent
longer sentences in the bachelor thesis
they induce before this is suspicious
say so we can make a look at this is
done without regarding no classified
nothing like this just the text take the
sentence length and compare it and you
have something you can think about
it says nothing we do is classify this
is done in the next steps what we have
in what I have in the data set is this
group 12 group 9 group 9 is the youngest
from last year it's not much in it the
group's 125 are complete I have the
bachelor thesis in all the reports and
the seminar papers this is a set of data
I have it's about 10 megabytes i can
give you the presentation there's no
problem you can download it I think from
Wolfram they can download it also from
my home page which is given on the last
slide so stay tuned and the text i
cannot give the way because these are
due confidential and regarding with
problems in the in the companies and so
this is not possible but you can have
the code it's no problem the first time
attempt here is simple the first I tried
given the text of the of the reports and
given the bachelor thesis so let's see
what class if I makes i put this simply
in classified type I've made a little
function here it doesn't matter what how
it is done but you see the result on the
last line its poor we have a classifier
function the measurement and you see we
have accuracy of ten percent this is not
good so using the whole data set is not
the key it is too large you have 89
classes and the lots of texts so this is
too complicated we can easily calculate
the hits by the way the specialist ii
these this data set is transparent for
the most functions so the function z
through so we have very fast the hits
here and we can now have nine hits often
out of 89 this is a bad result when we
took not only the hits but the top five
hits we have a 415 result not a good
ratio but better we can do so because a
lot of students come from the same
company so the texts are similar
yes and this is sick fest in this number
here if you classify a single group
results are much better I've chosen here
group for one of the first five groups
where I have a bachelor thesis and we
have here eighteen participants in this
group we have four other small small
groups its private universities or a
privilege to have small amount of people
in my groups 16 of this did the bachelor
thesis and we if we do a classification
here we get by far better result we have
an accuracy of fifty-six percent and an
air of 43 and have nine correctly
classified students out of 16 or
finished this is by far better than
using the whole group we can visualize
is this I can go a bit more quickly over
the slide because we have seen something
like this this is a confusion matrix
plot to see the person names on the Left
which the actual class is the predicted
class and then the main diagonal you see
the hits where everything is fine this
is a nice feature from this classifier
measurement functions when we do it up
five rating here so we identify a person
original and the top five of the class
we have a hit rate of 13 this is 13 out
of 16 people it's really good so for me
as a corrector of this bachelor thesis
it could say could sound like this look
at these three theses which are not
correct half their closer look because
these may be suspicious we have
sometimes discussions with yes it is so
with how do you call it is a Labor
Council of the company's a thing where
the students come from what about the
data are you allowed to do a hunt for
plagorism with electronic media this is
a maybe German specific discussion but
we have this and I'm not in all cases
allowed to use
texts to identify the thesis because the
company says no this is confidential you
may read the text by what you are not
allowed to process the text it's funny
but it is so it's not made from me I was
angry about that so we can do a
classification without the text it is
not so good like the text sure but it
works the first one can do is here's a
bit of code you can look at it but it's
not necessary for now the first what we
do is to classify only using the rate of
different we're at a person uses this is
rather specific for the the works of the
students written in the report form of
2500 words but we have here only one hit
this is clearly not possible to use the
rate it is to worse why is this so now
if you count the different words in
inner text this rate decreases the
longer the text is if it just rather
short text of 2500 words we have about
forty four percent different words in it
and if it is specially bachelor thesis
we have about thirty percent it
decreases interesting as that this also
in Prak you can make a nonlinear model
and fit it and to get in a limit rate
for each individual student or for each
individual person by the way traumas mum
has a bit more higher rate of twenty
percent than the Scientific American of
the last ten years it was only nineteen
percent in the limit but this is here
the problem that we can it cannot
classify this by rate because the
bachelor thesis differs from the from
the amount of words you see this here if
you are again the papers and the
bachelor thesis and the different words
in the bachelor thesis is by far higher
than in in the papers so we came out
yeah sure sure sure yes no no I have a
few students which wrote their practical
terms in English language but up to now
only one who wrote a bachelor thesis in
English but this is I haven't I haven't
put this in different bins up to now you
have with language you can the language
identify with the classifier what
language is this whether it's germinal
or whether it's English but it doesn't
count here when you have only a rate of
different words it is a rate in German
are in English but it would be
interesting to 2-under to decide whether
or to analyze where the difference are I
was also asked in in prac of whether I
have done some gender specific
investigation I would have done if there
are mere more women in my courses i have
only three so it is not well it to do
any analyzation here the most male in my
students
yeah yes sure sure but this is always
native language they are all written in
German they should have be able to do
this exactly to be both presses precise
now you see here this is a great
difference so you cannot compare it what
we can do we have a bachelor thesis of
about fourteen thousand words it's just
nuts large amount and we have the
records of two and a half thousand words
we can slide a window of 2500 words
length over the bachelor thesis and
count the different words and make the
mean so we would get a more appropriate
result doing this we get the following
actually I geographic it I think it's
enough we see it is more homogeneous we
have here the bachelor thesis smoothened
around with this window and choose
calculated the different words we have
there and if we do now the
classification we have a hit of seven so
the group has 16 people in it and
without knowing the text only taking in
account the rate of different words and
this sliding window we can add identify
seven persons this is not too bad it's
not good I have a few minutes I show you
something better but it is possible this
is a first attempt one can make even
hear an improvement we can put again not
only the rate of the different words but
on to the mean sentence length or the
mean word lengths the people use and
then if you do so I've done this with a
few convenience functions for me that
extract simply the data from the data
set you see the CD as build data set
build makes an exit at a set with a row
data where you have the data and you
have your classes it's the full name of
the student and other functions simply
extract these columns and make the
classification because it is not
possible to work directly this classify
on a data set so I have to extract them
but when you do it so it's working fine
so if we do so we have a bit better we
have eight persons
identified form over seven when we to
put apart the sentence length and the
word length we have a bit improvement
but it is still bad this can be done if
I am NOT allowed to use the words in the
indices Isis and in the reports there
are cases are not allowed I regret this
but the things god what you also can do
is you can use histograms you can make
very simple the histogram of the words
and sentences in the bachelor thesis and
you have data something shown like this
year the first three entries are shown
three histograms and the number the
number is a rate of different words the
others are the histograms of the word
length and the sentence length and you
can use this to identify persons again
you have a hit rate of eight okay then
I'm not using the histograms it is for
time reasons it took a lot of time to
calculate here the classification in the
last slide I will show you a diagram of
the calculation times it is here if I
have it right in mind about two minutes
for this 16 people two minutes it's as
large and if you have a word list it is
0 point two seconds so we may not
discuss this looking on the next part
classifying with lists we are in a much
more comfortable situation so we have a
list of words we can extract the words
the whole ceases we have though we have
a direct access to the text of the
ceases and doing so classifying the text
you see here a word list of a text in
this case I extract all the words with
multiplicity 2 3 this is the word
student used three times in his thesis
or in its records I've also show you in
soon worthless with multiplicity 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 though the number of words
decreases and the accuracy increases
here we have eight correct again a
confusion matrix plot with this
it's better if you do the top five
rating we got the hits of 14 out of 16
people this is quite good only to a Miss
quality classified if I do the top 5
rating here and I have to theses which
need a closer look to this is cumbersome
task to heip a closer look and hunting
for plagiarism by hand okay what we do
next I analyze the situation when I have
word lists of varying length when I have
a word list with multiplicity 1 the word
list is rather long sure I have the list
of different words here too is the list
of different words used twice by the
student you see that the computing time
goes down sure multiplicity 8 is only a
few words the student uses eight times
in its inner ceases and the accuracy
goes down we have here a graph showing
this if you have all the words are
allowed to use all the words I extract
all the words you have more than eighty
percent this is a good ratio they have
an error with about eighteen percent and
eighty percent you are correct when
using here the multiplicities can see is
also in a bar chart deceive can you see
it it's certain certain is identified
correct when I use simply the word list
from the bachelor thesis and use this
word list to classify the text so have a
nice right here to identify what is
funny I've not in this presentation if I
take the word lists as the data I put in
there's a test data the training data
sorry and thus a test that are the words
the student uses three times in a
bachelor thesis I have better results I
don't know why when I don't use the
words in the bachelor thesis but only
the words they use at minimum three
times with multiplicity 3 I got here 14
and not threaten I have no idea why but
it's what it yourself
if you look at the word count here in
the first case we have a very very bad
accuracy you can see this in this map
and this graphic here we have an
accuracy with its sorry yes should be
this accuracy of about forty percent
with multiplicity aid it is not good but
if you take into account that we have
this forty percent with only analyzing
65 words out of 2500 this is not too bad
I was very surprised by this but it is
possible to do so 65 words is not not
much it's a few lines few lines
extracted from the ceases and you are
able to with a forty percent probability
you are able to say okay this guy has
written it and if you take the whole
word list it is 438 you have only to
extract 438 words the different words
and you have an eighty-seven percent
accuracy in identifying the person who
has written the thesis this is a great
result for me because when I'm allowed
to use this text I do a pre-processing
and a half then three or four you for
negative hits say so three or four
theses where you have to take a closer
look which are suspicious the length is
this is an average number oh yes I
should mention it this is an average
number 438 the maximum here it's easily
calculated is 621 so the student with
the richest words uses in 621 different
words to write down a 2500 word long
revered now when can't discuss whether
this is good over this bed but it's
simply its first its effect looking at
the time we get an overview here result
for group was classifying this is the
timing here on the left side of this cup
of beer chart
VAR chart and word list of length 3 has
a hit rate of eighty seven point five
percent and a computing time this is
difficulty it's so small from outage of
about two seconds and the histogram I
mentioned here we have thirty one
percent accuracy is not too good but we
have a computation time from nearly two
minutes so the best one can do is to
make wordless classify used here
automatically by magnetic as a Markov
and its really lightning-fast order two
seconds is good a histogram there are
different methods used from Mathematica
automatically and maybe this is the time
consuming part here the others are also
rather egg fast you can use its the best
the worst is five dot 29 seconds so it's
very good results in a of eighty-one
percent accuracy okay that's for the for
the point thank you for your attention
now if time two questions here the
contacts you can see the presentation
soon on my website and surely also in
warfare research thank you